Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I hope that you will find this really useful. Thank you for being part of my world. Today is a special request from Henein who got in contact. And she says, I'm thinking about what might be beneficial for aspiring psychologists, could be power imbalances during our sessions and how to address these. And also maybe how we take into account social factors and inequalities when working with clients and families. So thank you so much for your request, Henaen. I will do my very best to answer that for you because it is a great question. So thank you. So when I was applying for doctorate places myself, I had a tendency to reflect on fiduciary relationships, which might not be a relationship that you have heard of before. But a fiduciary relationship is one where someone else has, you know, a duty of care for the other person.
我是Marianne Trent博士，希望你能从中获益。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。今天的内容是应听众Henein的特别要求。她说：“我在思考对有抱负的心理学家有益的话题，比如咨询过程中的权力失衡以及如何处理这些问题。还有，在与客户和家庭合作时，我们如何考虑社会因素和不平等问题。”非常感谢你的提问，Henaen。我会尽我所能为你解答，因为这是一个非常棒的问题。谢谢。当我申请博士学位时，我倾向于反思“信托关系”（fiduciary relationships），这可能是一个你以前没听过的词。信托关系是指一方对另一方负有某种照护责任的关系。
So one person is coming along because they need something, or maybe not always because they need something, they might not think that they need anything, but one of you has a duty of care or some kind of responsibility for the other person so we would get fiduciary relationships if we were a psychologist and we had a client we'd get them if you were a GP you get them if you were a dentist you know or an occupational therapist you know speech and language therapist all of these professions would be, whether they knew it or not, because it's not a very common term, would be subject to fiduciary relationships. And there are obviously, you know, there's caveats to that, that can make relationships
所以，一方前来是因为他们需要某些东西，或者不一定是因为他们需要什么——他们可能认为自己不需要任何东西——但你们中的一方对另一方负有照护义务或某种责任。如果我们是心理学家，我们与客户之间就存在信托关系；如果你是全科医生、牙医、职业治疗师或言语治疗师，这些职业无论是否意识到（因为这不是一个常用术语），都属于信托关系。当然，这其中有一些限制条件，可能会使关系
a bit more complicated. And, you know, so along the lines of the boundary setting episode, which I believe from the top of my head is episode eight, there are limits to our relationship. And of course, our relationships should be friendly with our service users. They should be, you know personable i believe um although i have you know previously worked in a service where an hour is dynamic and so um that is a slightly different type of relationship but you're still polite you know you're not rude to people um so yeah it's it's worth thinking about um those power imbalances you know I know that many clients I've worked with
变得复杂。正如我们在关于设定界限的那一集（我记得应该是第八集）中所讨论的，我们的关系是有局限的。当然，我们与服务对象的关系应该是友好的，应该是平易近人的。虽然我以前在某个服务机构工作时，那里的动态有所不同，那是另一种类型的关系，但你仍然要保持礼貌，不能对人粗鲁。所以，思考这些权力失衡是很有价值的。我知道我合作过的许多客户
have wanted to call me Dr Trent and I say to them you know you don't have to call me Dr Trent you can just call me Marianne but for them perhaps culturally or because it's just the way they've been brought up they want to continue to call me Dr. Trent. And I respect that about them, you know. I'm not going to correct them every time. I will explain that with them, you know, once. But many of them do still want to call me Dr. Trent. And clients that I might have been working with, you know, for over a year,
都想称呼我为Trent博士，我会告诉他们：“你不必叫我Trent博士，叫我Marianne就行。”但对他们来说，也许是出于文化原因，或者仅仅是因为他们的成长方式，他们还是想称呼我为Trent博士。我尊重他们这一点。我不会每次都纠正他们。我会向他们解释一次，但他们中的许多人仍然想叫我Trent博士。有些我合作了一年多的客户，
still message me in emails formally as Dr. Trent. But obviously to my face might call me Marianne. But, you know, we're not we're not correcting or dismissing what a client brings to them. But, you know, we do have to be very careful with how we are handling our power and our responsibility. And, you know, just to go over some of the boundaries stuff again, we have to make sure that we are being clear about the caveats to our role. We need to make sure that people have insight and can make an informed consent, knowing what, you know, what therapy and dealing with us as a service entails for them. So yeah, you can't ever really talk too long about consent and about the limits of confidentiality.
在邮件中仍然正式地称呼我为Trent博士，但面对面时可能会叫我Marianne。我们不会纠正或否定客户带来的东西，但我们确实必须非常小心地处理我们的权力和责任。再次重申界限问题，我们必须确保明确我们角色的局限性。我们需要确保人们有洞察力并能做出知情同意，了解治疗以及与我们合作意味着什么。所以，关于同意和保密限制的话题，怎么讨论都不为过。
And, you know, sometimes it can be useful to say, you know, this applies for all of our sessions together. But sometimes people start the beginning of every session by saying, you know, a little something about confidentiality again. But yeah, we do need to be mindful of the impact that we have over others, you know, and it's my clients seem to have a great deal of impact over what I watch on on Netflix, because they will often tell me what they're watching. And then I think, oh, well, I feel like I don't want to miss out on the party. I feel like I need to get involved with that. And, you know, I might have had a similar impact on you
有时，说明这些原则适用于我们所有的咨询过程是有用的。有时人们会在每次咨询开始时再次提及保密性。但我们确实需要注意我们对他人的影响。我的客户似乎对我看Netflix的内容有很大影响，因为他们经常告诉我他们在看什么，然后我就想：“哦，我不想错过这个潮流，我觉得我得参与进去。”而且，我可能也对你有过类似的影响，
when I spoke about This Is Us. You know, maybe recently you listened to that and you're like, well, I've never watched This Is Us, but she says that's all right. You know, because you become a bit of an influencer, don't you, when you're chatting about things. So, yeah, we can have shared experiences with our clients, but we also have to know that there are differences. And this is really useful fodder for supervision as well. And, you know, whilst you might have shared characteristics with your client, we have to be careful that we're not over identifying or diminishing our clients experiences because we have some understanding of what they've been through.
当我谈到《我们这一天》（This Is Us）时。也许你最近听了那一集，心想：“我从没看过《我们这一天》，但她说那很好。”当你谈论某些事情时，你确实会成为某种影响者。所以，我们可以与客户分享经验，但我们也必须知道存在差异。这对于督导来说也是非常有用的素材。虽然你可能与客户有共同的特征，但我们必须小心，不要因为对他们的经历有一定了解，就过度认同或贬低客户的经历。
But, you know, sometimes our clients will purposefully seek us out, especially in private practice, because they believe that we will know with um with what they're talking about let's take a short break here and i will be back with you on the other side of this um this break hi my name is mark i'm an assistant psychologist in a specialist autism team in liverpool and i've just gotten onto the doctorate in exeter starting this september the aspiring psychologist podcast has been great for me the content and the guests guests are brilliant and I think Marianne does a really good job as a host of being really positive, normalising negative experiences and reminding people to be compassionate towards themselves. For me the podcast is especially useful because I feel like I'm always busy and on the run-up to interviews I could listen to it whilst I was at the gym and it
但是，有时我们的客户会特意寻找我们，特别是在私人执业中，因为他们相信我们了解他们所谈论的内容。让我们在这里休息一下，休息过后我会回来。嗨，我叫Mark，是利物浦一家自闭症专家团队的助理心理学家，我刚刚被埃克塞特大学的博士项目录取，今年九月入学。《有抱负的心理学家》播客对我帮助很大，内容和嘉宾都很棒。我认为Marianne作为主持人做得非常好，她非常积极，将负面经历常态化，并提醒人们要善待自己。对我来说，这个播客特别有用，因为我总是很忙，在面试前我可以在健身房听它，它
allowed me to feel as though I was still getting that important time for myself and do things that are important for me whilst still engaging with stuff that is going to help me on my psychology journey without needing to carve out any separate and dedicated time for it. I definitely recommend that anyone wanting to know more about working in psychology give this podcast a listen, as it gives a really clear and honest insight into the things you can expect. Okay, welcome back. So I was talking to a journalist yesterday about eating alone and cooking alone for ourselves, and how that can be an ultimate act of self-care but I also asked her
让我觉得我仍然拥有那段重要的个人时间，在做对自己重要的事情的同时，还能接触到有助于我心理学之旅的内容，而无需专门腾出时间。我绝对推荐任何想了解心理学工作的人听听这个播客，因为它提供了非常清晰和诚实的见解。好了，欢迎回来。昨天我和一位记者谈到了独自吃饭和独自做饭，以及这如何成为一种终极的自我关怀行为。但我同时也请她
to make reference to the fact that for many people currently it would feel like a bit of a a decadent thing to do to be perhaps switching an oven on just for ourselves or you know using all the resources of using a gas hob and then having to wash up all of the stuff just for one person and I think unless you've got some awareness of the social context of that unless you've yeah just taken that on board then we need to be make, we need to make sure that some of the suggestions and some of the things we might be discussing with clients, you know, for activity scheduling, for example, or for building structure and routine into life to make it more functional and enjoyable. We do need to make sure that we're not, you know,
提到一个事实：对许多人来说，仅仅为了自己一个人开烤箱，或者使用燃气灶的所有资源，然后还要洗碗，这在目前看来可能是一种奢侈的行为。我认为，除非你对其中的社会背景有所了解，除非你已经意识到了这一点，否则我们需要确保我们向客户提出的建议，比如活动安排，或者为了让生活更具功能性和乐趣而建立结构和常规，我们必须确保我们不是
socially unaware of what it is like for our service users to be trying to navigate the world at the moment, when they might well be, you know, scared of, you know, factors associated with the pandemic. They might, you know, be struggling financially to heat homes or put food on the table. And so it's really useful to have conversations with people, even when it might look like they couldn't possibly be struggling for money. It's useful to check in with people about, you know, some of the factors from the Maslow's hierarchy, just to check how things are for them financially, how things, you know, you're not asking for bank statements here, but if someone is really struggling to pay their water bill or you know they're worried that they can't you know can't cover the cost of the next food shop that really does impact
对服务对象目前在世界上试图应对的生活状态缺乏社会认知。他们可能很害怕与疫情相关的因素，可能在经济上难以支付取暖费或购买食物。因此，与人们进行对话非常有用，即使看起来他们不可能缺钱。询问人们关于马斯洛需求层次理论中的一些因素是很有用的，只是为了检查他们的财务状况。你不是在索要银行对账单，但如果有人真的难以支付水费，或者担心无法负担下一次买菜的费用，那确实会产生巨大的影响。
on people in in a big and important way and I had a recent conversation with a client where it came came to light that they they weren't really sure how they were going to fill their cupboards next time. And so we used a bit of our time in the session to look at options for, you know, emergency food provision. And that then freed the client up to feel validated to feel seen and it wasn't done in a way at all to be shaming but to just feel like they had other options available to them because if you feel like you can't feed yourself or your children then it's you don't know where your next meal is coming from it's very difficult to think about anything else you know because it can really dominate things so it's important for us to have conversations even though it might be very different to your own experiences currently so I know everybody
我最近与一位客户交谈时发现，他们真的不知道下次该如何填满橱柜。因此，我们在咨询中花了一些时间寻找紧急食物供应的方案。这让客户感到被认可、被看见，而且这种方式一点也不羞辱人，只是让他们觉得还有其他选择。因为如果你觉得无法养活自己或孩子，不知道下一顿饭在哪里，就很难去思考其他事情，因为它真的会占据一切。所以，即使这与你目前的经历非常不同，进行这些对话也很重要。我知道每个人
is feeling the pinch of increased cost of living. But where people, where clients have got limited resources because the benefits haven't been increased, then, you know, the pressures are going to be that much more, really, than if you're working with a client who is able to put up their wages or put up their rates or, you know, go out there and earn more money just by picking up some more clients, for example. So just having an awareness of the social factors that are around right now can be really useful. And similarly, you know, when I've worked with clients who are in social housing it's very difficult to imagine if you aren't in that context yourself about just what an impact it has upon you if you are living in close proximity to you know a crack den for example which is something that
都感受到了生活成本增加的压力。但当客户因为福利没有增加而资源有限时，压力确实会比那些能够提高工资、提高费率，或者通过接更多客户来赚更多钱的客户要大得多。因此，了解当前的社会因素非常有用。同样，当我与住在社会保障房的客户合作时，如果你自己没有那种背景，就很难想象住在毒窝附近会对你产生多大的影响，
one of my clients had experienced and the impact that has on you have been able to smell crack all the time and feeling like it's in your home and you know it's affecting your health and so you know sometimes even just having a conversation about your home what it's like how you feel to be there when you're there. Does it feel like a place of sanctuary or are there factors that make it very tricky? So they might not tell you about some of these factors just unless you ask, because there may be a great deal of shame or stigma.
这是我的一位客户经历过的。那种一直能闻到毒品味、感觉它就在你家里、影响你健康的感觉。所以，有时仅仅是谈论你的家，它是什么样的，你在那里感觉如何，这很重要。它感觉像是一个避难所，还是有一些因素让它变得非常棘手？除非你问，否则他们可能不会告诉你这些因素，因为可能存在大量的羞耻感或污名化。
And similarly, I work with someone else who's got, I would do work with them, don't work with them anymore, and their neighbor's dogs were incredibly noisy. And it was, you know, affecting all areas of their well being, really. And it was incredibly difficult, but it wasn't something that I never I necessarily would have thought to ask about had we not been doing a bit of a rundown of, you know, of what it's like to be them, you know, take me through your day from morning to night and, you know, give me a flavour of some of the things that crop up for you in that day. So that can be a really useful exercise, getting to know your
同样，我曾与另一个人合作——我现在不再与他们合作了——他们的邻居的狗非常吵。这确实影响了他们幸福感的方方面面。这非常困难，但如果不是我们对他们的生活进行了一次梳理——比如“带我走过你从早到晚的一天，让我感受一下你一天中出现的一些事情”——我未必会想到去问这些。所以，这可能是一个非常有用的练习，去了解你的
client and getting to know the unique struggles, which they might not necessarily be thinking are contributing to their difficulties, but as we know, they really can. If it's impacting on our sleep, or it's impacting on our ability to nourish or provide for ourselves or our children, then that can be very difficult indeed. And neighbour conflict is a big deal,
客户，去了解他们独特的挣扎。他们可能不认为这些因素导致了他们的困难，但我们知道，它们确实可以。如果它影响了我们的睡眠，或者影响了我们滋养自己或孩子的能力，那确实会非常困难。邻里冲突是一件大事，
because it can really make people feel, you know, vulnerable in their home. So these are important conversations to have. Yeah, I think being brave enough to ask questions, but also just saying, well, how is that for you? What's that like? Or being honest, I don't have any experience of growing up in a situation where, you know, English wasn't my first language, for example. How has that been for you? And I was recently doing a session with someone who spoke three or four languages. And so I asked them, well, how is it when I ask you questions in English and that isn't your first language can you tell me what goes on for you at that time and they were then able to answer you know what that
因为它真的会让人们在家里感到脆弱。所以，进行这些对话很重要。是的，我认为要勇敢地提出问题，也要说：“这对你来说怎么样？那是什么感觉？”或者诚实地说：“我没有在英语不是我的第一语言的环境中长大的经验。”例如，这对你来说是怎样的？我最近和一位会说三四种语言的人进行了一次咨询。所以我问他们：“当我用英语问你问题而那不是你的第一语言时，你能告诉我你当时是什么感觉吗？”他们随后能够回答
is like for them and they said that under pressure it does get a bit trickier but generally speaking they are able mostly to think about situations now in English but under pressure we will often revert back to our earliest coping strategies that might be worth knowing that for many of our clients that we might be working with their earliest coping strategies might not almost be, you know, within the British, if you're listening to this in Britain, they might not be socially that common within our British culture. So it's worth thinking with our clients about what makes them unique and about their coping strategies and their way of thinking about the world and what things have been like growing up and how that might be different for them now so many of my
那对他们来说是什么感觉。他们说在压力下确实会变得更棘手，但总的来说，他们现在大多能用英语思考。但在压力下，我们往往会回归到最早的应对策略。了解这一点可能很有价值，因为对于我们合作的许多客户来说，他们最早的应对策略可能在英国文化中并不常见。所以，与客户一起思考是什么让他们变得独特，思考他们的应对策略、他们看待世界的方式、成长过程中的经历，以及这些经历对他们现在的不同影响，是非常值得的。我的许多
clients in the past have have have then been not with their family you know not in the same birth not in the same country as their birth families and that has its own unique challenges as well. So yeah, just be open and interested and compassionate and wise and don't be afraid to ask how things are for your clients. Don't always assume that you know. You know, we really want to be getting a bespoke feel for your clients as being unique and valuable people and not just being treated as a number. So that's my own personal take on it. But yeah, I hope you found this useful. Henaen, I hope this was what you imagined it might be. But if it hasn't been, let me know and I can give it another go. Okay, thank you so much for listening. Please do take a moment
过去的客户都不和家人在一起，不在他们出生的国家，这也有其独特的挑战。所以，保持开放、好奇、富有同情心和智慧，不要害怕询问客户的情况。不要总是想当然。我们真的希望为你的客户提供一种定制化的感觉，让他们感到自己是独特且有价值的人，而不仅仅是被当作一个数字。这就是我个人的看法。希望你觉得这很有用。Henaen，希望这达到了你的预期。如果不是，请告诉我，我可以再试一次。好的，非常感谢你的收听。请花一点时间
to rate and review my podcast episodes on the Apple podcast app. Find me the aspiring psychologist podcast, scroll right to the bottom, right underneath the trailer. And that's where you'll find the rate and review section. So thank you so much for listening. If you would like to sign up to the waiting list for the Aspiring Psychologist membership, you can do that by checking out the details in the show notes or on my link tree. Thanks for listening and hope you have a lovely day. Take care. Psychologist. Then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
在Apple Podcast应用上为我的播客评分和评论。找到《有抱负的心理学家》播客，滚动到底部，就在预告片下方，你就会找到评分和评论部分。非常感谢你的收听。如果你想注册《有抱负的心理学家》会员候补名单，可以通过查看节目说明或我的Linktree链接来完成。感谢收听，祝你有美好的一天。保重。心理学家。让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你离获得资格就不远了。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，觉得我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。